طيب طبعا اصعب شيء انك انت تتحكم بشخص او
تقرا افكاره عن طريق الصوت فقط لانه تحتاج
التركيز عالي جدا
انا حسالك كم سؤال وابيك تكون صادق معاي
تمشي خطوه بخطوه معي ابد لك يعطيك شفافيه
يلا قول تمام
اول سؤال حاسالك رقم جوالك السري مكون من
سته ارقام او اربع ارقام
سته ارقام جميل انا ابيك تعد من الواحد
للتسعه بصوت عالي انا بحاول اني من خلال
استماعي للعد الارقام اني اتوقع رقمك
السري تمام طيب ابيك تسمي بالله وتبدا تعد
من الواحد الان واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه
خمسه سته سبعه ثمانيه تسعه
هسالك سؤال عادل انت تحس انه انت تنسى
الارقام السريه دائما تحط رقم واحد او رقم
متسلسل او شكل معين لان التلفون جديد حطيت
اول رقم خطر ببالي في شوي متسلسل شويه
كثير
جميل لازم تشوف شاشه التليفون عشان تعرف
تعرف الرقم ولا
خلاص حافظوا في راسك
على البصمه الوجه اكثر لكن انا حافظه بس
اشوفه واكتبه
حافظه
حافظ جميل جميل جميل جميل طيب انا الان
غيرت رقم جوالي السري والمفترض انه يكون
نفس رقم جوالك السري تمام لو في البدايه
نحط اي سته ارقام عشوائيه عندنا مستحيل
يفتح الجوال مهما كانت الارقام اي سته
ارقام عشوائيه ما حيفتح الجوال الا بسته
ارقام محدده عادل تسمح لي انك تصرح برقم
جوالك السري روح رقم رقم الحياه سعيده
طيب قولي اول رقم كم اثنين
رقم اثنين
كمل معاي صفر اثنين كم
اثنين صفر صفر
صفر صفر
صفر واحد
واحد هذا المتاكد ان هذا رقمك
اوكي
يعطيك العافيه عادل هذا باسورد مش معقول
مش معقول يعني هو الرقم
لحظه لحظه كيف
انا ترى حطيته لان هذا مو رقم الاساسي لكن
انا حطيتها على اساس انه هذا التلفون جديد
فبالتالي هو سهل لمتابعتي المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات